und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf uns marietta slomka
guten abend
kommissionspräsidentin ursula von der
leyen fordert von den eu ländern
schnelle waffenlieferungen an die
ukraine nur so können sie im abwehrkampf
gegen russland bestehen sagte von der
leyen der bild am sonntag
das wird aber nur geschehen wenn die
einzelnen eu-mitgliedsländer das wollen
in deutschland ist derzeit noch nicht
einmal klar wie schnell die
angekündigten zusätzlichen finanzmittel
an die ukraine ausgezahlt werden und ob
sie sich davon auch deutsche panzer
kaufen darf bemerkenswert dass es
seitens der bundesregierung immer noch
keine eindeutige kommunikation dazu gibt
derweil die russischen truppen in der
ukraine weiter vernichten und zerstören
einen überblick zum kriegsgeschehen von
christian von rechenberg
noch hat putins offensive im osten nicht
begonnen den bewohnern von capmark das
gleichgültig sein die stadt ist auch
ohne offensive unter dauerndem beschuss
fünf tote heute sagt die ukrainische
seite in maadi opel haben sich die
letzten ukrainischen kämpfer offenbar
auf dem gelände des stahlwerks of style
verschanzt heute hatten sie eine
entscheidung zu treffen wir fordern die
ukraine auf die waffen niederzulegen und
aufzugeben sie retten damit ihr leben
kapitulation abgelehnt russlands
reaktion postwendend man werde nun alle
ukrainischen kämpfer töten das dürfte
blutig werden für beide seiten die
verteidiger an mann und material 2
unterlegen doch das werk ist riesengroß
unübersichtlich präsident alan ski nennt
die lage äußerst schwierig und warnt
russland macht einen großen fehler wenn
sie an unsere leute in mario poll töten
und das wird passieren
dann kann das das ende jeglicher form
von verhandlungen bedeuten
verhandlungen frieden was für ein segen
wäre das für all die menschen in den
kellern und bunkern in der ost ukraine
in einem unter der stadt sidon netz
gelebt die 77 jährige tamara seit fünf
wochen
ich vermisse man zuhause sagt sie ich
will da hin zurück ich vermisse meine
frühere arbeit ich will wieder in meinem
garten sein
wo es sonnig und warm hier unten gibt's
kein tageslicht das ist kalt feucht
zweimal am tag verteilen sie das was
andere entbehren konnten immerhin etwas
zu essen etwas zu trinken
viele wurden krank hier unten sie husten
hatten andere symptome und so weiter und
so weiter das schlimmste war dass wir
keine medikamente hatten die ihnen
halfen
wo anders wie hier in borodjanka nach
ihr versuchen sie weiter das trümmerfeld
in den griff zu bekommen eine sisyphus
arbeit in der schwer getroffenen stadt
zum glück gibt es freiwillige die sich
um lebensmittel kümmern sie wollen so
lange bleiben wie sie gebraucht werden
frau partner braucht sie zu hause warten
zwei hungrige enkel
die hilfe ist grandios gottseidank
müssen wir nicht hungern für heute
reicht wir hoffen auf das beste hoffen
das ist das wenige das bleibt wenn
putins raketen jederzeit und überall
einschlagen können bei einer probe
trafen sie infrastruktur wie der
bürgermeister mitteilte russland
behauptet man habe eine munitionsfabrik
zerstört
um in die klassen meister ist für uns in
kiew dominique auch in china schauen ja
alle nach mario pohl mit der bangen
frage wie es dort weitergeht und was
dort geschieht
ja fällt mario pohl dann wäre das ein
wendepunkt in diesem krieg denn es ist
ja bisher so dass die ukraine mario polk
war sie noch als einzige stadt in der
kontrolle hat am asowschen meer der rest
ist bereits von russland besetzt und
deswegen kämpft die ukraine auch um
diese stadt und die ukraine versucht
natürlich auch die russischen truppen
dort hin zu halten weil man hat die
sorge dass diese woche diese offensive
im osten beginnt und man braucht zeit
man braucht zeit die truppen selbst neu
zu strukturieren um waffen aus europa
und den usa auch ins kampfgebiet zu
bringen und präsident seelands gerhard
heute noch mal eindringlich vor allem
auch an die europäer appelliert denn
schwere waffen zu liefern panzer zu
liefern denn das braucht die ukraine um
in einer offenen feldschlacht in der ost
ukraine
auch bestehen zu können auch sie bewegen
zu können gegen eine doch dann über
mächtige russische armee und deswegen
blickt natürlich auch in diesen stunden
war auch gerade auch normal
bombardements in mario pohl stattfinden
ja sehr auch gebannt auf diese diese
nacht auch in der ost ukraine
dankeschön ein wenig nach kiew
dieses bild aus der stadt im team geht
derzeit um die welt in einem waldstück
ein feld mit frischen gräbern und
blumenschmuck
eine junge ukrainische journalistin
twitterte dazu damit müssen wir jetzt
leben kann mir jemand sagen wie
während alle augen auf die ukraine
gerichtet sind sollte eine andere
europäische unruheregion aber nicht
gänzlich aus dem blick verloren werden
der westbalkan
russland hat dort eigene interessen und
sei es das interesse europa zu
destabilisieren und putins russland hat
dort glühende anhänger umso mehr muss
uns interessieren was es mit dem
flugabwehrsystem auf sich hat dass die
chinesen wohl kürzlich an serbien
lieferten dazu ein bericht von wolf
christian übrig
der flughafen belgrad bietet
flugzeugfans normalerweise keine großen
sensationen aber was nicola gaal jetzt
jetzt vor die kamera bekam hat ihn
umgehauen mehrere chinesische militär
frachter das hatte hier noch nicht
gesehen
ein historischer moment definitiv ein
historischer moment chinesische militär
flugzeuge in europa zu sehen ist
wirklich so real
an bord der maschinen so hört man
kostbare fracht ein chinesisches
flugabwehrsystem vor drei jahren
bestellt serbien modernisiert gerade
seine armee
die serbische armee ist heute um ein
vielfaches stärker als je zuvor und wir
glauben dass unsere stärke eine gute
abschreckung ist für alle die unsere
sicherheit in frage stellen
die lieferung passt in ein bekanntes
muster serbiens präsident bush macht
politik mit wechselnden partnern zum
eigenen nutzen unter patriotischer
flagge
so lässt er einerseits von russland
waffen liefern das ist auch
innenpolitisch populär weil russland für
viele serben der große bruder ist
diskreter kommuniziert dagegen dass
serbien am meisten geld für europäischer
waffen aus gibt unter anderem für
französische rafale-kampfjets
und auch mit china macht vucic
kerngeschäfte militärisch verbindet sie
ein gemeinsamer kontrahent die nato 1999
als die nato belgrad bombardiert um
kriegsverbrecher milosevic vom krieg im
kosovo abzuhalten traf sie versehentlich
auch die chinesische botschaft in china
und serbien teilen eine geschichte
nämlich fremde aggression zu widerstehen
wie wir zu sagen pflegen die
freundschaft zwischen zwei ländern wird
mit blut geschmiedeten
dass china nun jedoch waffen nach europa
liefert an dass russland freundliche
serbien mitten in putins krieg für
peking diplomatisch diffizil
wir hoffen dass die medien das nicht
überinterpretieren
dieses projekt hat mit der aktuellen
lage nichts zu tun
bis heute ist serbien das einzige land
auf dem balkan ohne präsenz von
nato-soldaten vujic schaukelpolitik
zwischen den weltmächten stößt jetzt
jedoch an grenzen er wird gehen die
fabrik in der ukraine ist entscheidend
um europa sagt du musst auf der einen
oder der anderen seite stehen die
serbische militärische neutralität und
der flirt mit allen seiten funktioniert
jetzt nicht mehr
alljährliche paraden täuschen nicht
darüber hinweg serbiens waffen sind
veraltet die nachbarstaaten reagierten
teils besorgtheit gelassen auf die
modernisierung sie ahnen mehr schein als
sein
in wirklichkeit hat die armee ein
problem mit dem personal viele sind
unzufrieden mit dem gehalt mit ihrem
status mit der stimmung in der armee und
die leute gehen
die nagelneue luftabwehr wäre da ein
schönes bild doch präsident vucic maxi
gerade nicht öffentlich vorstellen er
schaut vermutlich noch von wo der wind
der geschichte gerade weht
und jetzt macht erstmal heinz wolf
weiter mit den nachrichten wird das
zumindest etwas ist ehrlich nach
zweijähriger corona pause konnte papst
franziskus die ostermesse wieder auf dem
petersplatz in rom mit tausenden
gläubigen beginn der papst forderte in
seiner osterbotschaft ein ende des
ukraine krieges und erinnerte an krisen
und konflikte weltweit der frieden sei
eine pflicht und verantwortung aller
traditionell erteilte der papst zum
abschluss den segen urbi et orbi der
stadt und dem erdkreis
auch in deutschland haben die kirchen in
den oster botschaften das leid in der
ukraine angeprangert der vorsitzende der
deutschen bischofskonferenz bätzing
sagte man gebe die hoffnung nicht auf
dass sich die welt zum guten für dann
könne und dass man alles daran setzen
müsse der evangelische landesbischof in
bayern bedford strohm erinnerte an die
verzweifelten menschen in der ukraine
und auch an die russischen soldaten
mütter die umgefallene söhne trauerten
nach den feierlichkeiten zum
nationalfeiertag hat nordkorea den test
zweier raketen gemeldet wie staatsmedien
berichten handelt es sich bei den
lenkraketen um ein neues system für
taktische atomwaffen
nordkorea hat seit beginn des jahres
bereits mehrere tests unternommen
international besteht die sorge das land
könne erstmals seit 2017 auch wieder
kernwaffen testen
die gewerkschaften wollen angesichts der
steigenden preise in den kommenden
tarifrunden lohnerhöhungen durchsetzen
insbesondere gering und
normalverdienende seien belastet sagte
der dgb-vorsitzende hoffmann dem
redaktions netzwerk deutschland der
inflationsausgleich bleibe auch in
dieser schweren krise ein hauptziel der
tarifpolitik
gesundheitsminister lauterbach erwartet
für september einen corona impfstoff der
an die omikron variante angepasst ist
was könnte ich dir lauterbach in der
bild am sonntag an er verwies
gleichzeitig auf mögliche neue varianten
und schutzmaßnahmen im herbst aktuell
sinkt die sieben tage incident sie liegt
bei 800 34,3 weil über die feiertage
weniger getestet wird könnten die zahlen
laut rk jedoch verzerrt sein
stichwort feiertage am ende dieses
sonnigen ostersonntags dann noch ein
blick in die feriengebiete eines
stadtfeld mit eindrücken von der ostsee
mit dem osterfest beginnt die
tourismussaison in mecklenburg
vorpommern strahlender sonnenschein und
milde temperaturen locken die ersten
urlauber vor allem an die küste wie hier
in kühlungsborn in ihrem hotel
restaurant dekoriert christine bands
noch schnell die stellvertretende
direktorin packt überall mit an im hotel
gilt weiter 3g im restaurant nicht mehr
das erleichtert ihr den saisonauftakt
wir arbeiten weiter nach 3g verordnung
sind es aber inzwischen auch geübt und
aber für die gastronomie für die
restaurants und für alles ist das ganz
wichtig dass da jetzt auch wieder
lockerungen in kraft treten
ihr hotel in erster reihe am strand das
so gut wie ausgebucht insgesamt werden
rund 300.000 gäste während der
osterferien inland erwartet urlaub hier
wird allerdings teurer bis zu 15 prozent
gestiegene kosten für energie und
lebensmittel schlagen durch das macht
auch christine bands sorgen und man sich
überlegt dass ein kilo roastbeef über
zehn euro mehr kostet als noch vor
kurzem
ich denke man sieht auch überall gewisse
preissteigerungen lassen sich nicht
vermeiden die urlauber schrecke das aber
nicht ab wenn ich das die leistung haben
möchte die ich dich hier bekommen wir
dann muss ich eben auch mit diesen
preisen leben ja vielleicht mal eine
cola ist weniger als sonst aber
ansonsten lassen wir uns davon
eigentlich nicht groß beeindrucken ja
neben deutlichen mehrausgaben kämpfen
die touristiker außerdem mit
personalmangel während der pandemie
haben viele mitarbeiter den beruf
gewechselt
55 der unternehmen sagen uns aktuell das
in mitarbeiterinnen mitarbeiter fehlen
das heißt es ist ein problem das sich
durch bewohner verstärkt hat und auch
nicht von heute auf morgen zu lösen ist
die branche rechnet in diesem jahr mit
etwa 10 millionen gästen in mv das käme
den rekordjahren schon sehr nahe
zum fussball hand diesem sonntag in der
bundesliga gab es vier spiele mit diesen
ergebnissen bielefeld bayern 0 zu 3
union berlin eintracht frankfurt 2 zu 0
hoffenheim greuther fürth 0 zu 0
leverkusen leipzig null zu eins im
frauen dfb pokal steht das erste
endspiel team fest wolfsburg hat sich im
halbfinale 3 2 1 gegen den fc bayern
durchgesetzt und trifft im finale auf
leverkusen oder potsdam und jetzt noch
die wetteraussichten für die kommenden
tage am ostermontag ziehen über die
osthälfte einige wolken dabei werden
zehn bis 16 grad erreicht in der
westhälfte scheint meist die sonne und
die temperatur steigt auf 16 bis 20 grad
die nächsten tage bringen neben sonne
überall auch wolkenfelder aber nur am
dienstag fällt im südosten etwas regen
die nächte bleiben kalt tagsüber werden
9 bis 20 grad erreicht
das was uns an diesem ostersonntag um 23
50 gibt es dann die nächste heute
express und hier erwarten sie morgen
bettina schausten und gundula gause auf
wiedersehen wieder sinn
[Musik]